各位观众大家好
我是朱立安
祝您投资
顺利也然
申平安
今天要跟大家分享的主题是
唐奇安的交易指南
节目开始要请各位同学订阅袁老师
也就是我朱立安的分析师
个人YT频道
那这个爱迪赛科塔
他说
他是一个投资高手
交易高手
他说交易的执行
就是doing
的部分呢很简单
你只需要拿起电话筒
然后下单
这样就可以了很简单
但是呢你要成为一名真正的
真正的交易者呢
这个程序更是微妙
那就好像成为一名运动员一样
你要投入承诺
还有坚守使命
这是爱迪赛科塔交易高手
他所说的
那我们这个YT频道
我们的影片会分享潜力股
到6月6号为止
我们推荐的
就上个礼拜的这个潜力股
有哪些呢
有益然
这是AI的数据
大数据
云端大数据服务的公司
AI运用
AI弱地应用的公司
很强
益然
3128的
森瑞
富士达
凯硕
台湾名版
台光店
韦影
JPPKY
还有安泰克
这些都是上个礼拜表现比较强的股票
好
那就记得加入我们的这个LINEAT
小老鼠451VQTY
加入我们的LINEAT
有千张大物的资讯
整理过后的千张大物资讯
还有基本面标股资讯
那还没订阅我们的YT频道呢
请按开启影片下方的连结
按赞订阅开启小铃铛
那我们这个单元的大纲呢
是唐锡安的一般指南
一般指南交易的范例
那谁是唐锡安呢
唐锡安他是这个
被誉为趋势交易之父
我看到这个名称呢
就知道他大有来头,非常响亮的名号。
他在1934年就开始使用机械化交易系统,
他是商品交易股闻所谓的CTA制度的开创者。
他在1970年代提出简单的移动平均线的交叉系统,
成为许多城市化交易的基础。
那唐锡安的一般交易的指南
第一个就是接纳普遍的意见
公开意见即使正确
也常常导致行动的延迟
那是这样子
因为市场的看法
普遍看法
比如说新闻报道或分析师的看法
可能是正确的
但是由于散户或机构反应滞后
动作稍微没有那么快
没有那么迅速啊
价格往往已经反映了这些消息
进场可能为时已晚啊
啊
比如说2023年啊
市场普遍预期某科技股
比如说就是这个NVIDIA
因为AI热潮将会上涨当新闻广泛报导的时候呢股价已经从150美元涨到了200美元最高买进的很可能在200美元进场
但是随后因为市场消化力多
而回整至180美元
这个就是接纳普遍的意见
第二个是观察成交量
在市场沉闷或无动性时
注意成交量增加的方向
并且准备顺势回挡
市场在低位波动或者盘整期后呢
成交量突然增加
通常会伴随着趋势的启动
应该准备顺着成交量增加的方向来教育
但是注意很有可能会有短期的回挡
例如说某一个商品黄金
在2024年3月
价格在1800到1850美元区间
整理数周
成交量低迷
某一天呢
价格突然突破1850美元
同时呢
成交量飙升到平均成交量
比如说月均量的两倍
最后短暂回挡到1830元
然后继续上涨至1900美元
就是这个意思
那停损和让利润成长
就是无论其他规则怎么样呢
限制损失
并且让利润成长
这是一个最重要的核心概念
那这个就这样解释
设定停损来控制风险
同时允许获利的交易继续运行
避免过早平仓
那比如说有投资人呢
100美元买进某式股票
设定10%的停损就是90块
那股价上涨到150元以后呢
继续持仓
那最终呢上涨到200元
那但是呢万一不幸
股价没有涨反而跌
跌破90元的时候呢
就要立即停损
那这个原则适用所有的风险交易
就是所有的有风险的交易
都适用并且强调纪律风险的管理
清仓操作明朗市场
在市场方向明朗的时候保持清仓
就是说这个部位不要太大
那最明确的趋势讯号
避免无谓的波动损失
可以这样解释
在市场方向不明的时候
一定要降低部位
减少风险
减低风险
专注于明显的趋势讯号
避免间歇交易导致的损失
那即使市场趋势很明显
也应该控制仓位
避免过度暴露在风险之中
那比如说有这个投资者
在2020年6月观察原油的市场
价格在70到75美元
没有波动
波动没有方向
就是在这边区间横向整理
那交易者他先保持的10%的部位
等在价格
价格等待突破75元的时候呢
就确认趋势以后
加码到50%的这个部位
那再来呢就是
避免跟随短期波动避免在连续三天连续三天的价格波动方向上建仓等待短线的单日反转讯号
连续三天同向波动以后
市场可能出现回档
应该等待短线的单日反转讯号在行动
比如说某只股票
连续三天从50元涨到56元
第四天价格
下跌到54美元
但是成交量萎缩下降
所以我们就等待第四天
确认上涨后呢
在54美元进场做多
随后价格恢复上涨到60美元
就是这个意思
好那这个呢
是善用停损单
停损单可以用在保护利润
限制损失
或在特定的形态
譬如说三角形的这个形态当中
建立部位建仓
需要结合图表形态使用
那比如说停损单解释
是停损单是保护资金和锁定利润的工具
特别是在特定形态
比如说三角形突破的时候
设置停损单来控制风险
那假设某只股票形成上升三角形
价格在80到85美元震荡
交易者在86元设置买入停损单
当价格突破86元的时候
自动就建立部位了
美国他们就有这种下单的
86美元突破的时候买进
这种方式
并涨至90元
同时在78美元设置停损单
限制损失就是呃
万一跌破78美元
那就呃78美元那就停损出场
那那这个就是啊这水平的地方啊
水平呢就是85啊水平就是85啊
那这个三角形上升三角形在这边震荡啊
突破水平的呃85压力区来到86的时候
这时候可以买进啊
万一再跌破78元就出场啊
那如果顺利的时候就往上攻了
好
那这个就是上升三角形
那再来呢
顺势加仓
上涨趋势大于强于下跌趋势行情中呢
看多应该持有较重的部位
因为上涨的潜力大于下跌的潜力
这是从几率的观点来看的
好
那我们譬如说在明确的上升趋势当中
可以考虑逐步加码持仓
同样是在25到50的区间呢
这股价从50跌到25
只能获利50%的利润
但是呢
如果说从25涨到50呢
就可以获得100%的利润
所以要看哪一方的这个几率大
如果是在上涨趋势呢
就是要看多
要做多的部位持有较多
好
那比如说
2023年
比特币呈现了上涨的趋势
从3万美元涨到
4万5千美元
那交易者在
3万5千美元
就是建立部位建仓50%然后确认趋势之后呢在4万美元加再加码到80%
最终上涨到4万5千美元
那这个就是顺势加仓
再来呢
进场与出场的策略
建仓的时候
建仓的时候使用限价单
平仓的时候使用市价单
好那建仓的时候用现价单设定理想的价格
控制进场的价位
可以比较这个好整以下的方式
那找到一个比较好的价位
那如果说要平仓的时候呢
就直接用市价单确保快速的执行
那比如说有个投资人买一只股票
100元的时候设定现价单买进
那结果成功的
在99.5元这个成交
但是当价格涨到120美元的时候呢
决定平仓
这时候呢
要利用市价单立即卖出
避免滑点损失
好那这个再来呢
选择强势股
买进价格走势表现强势
产业背景强势的股票
卖出相对弱势的股票
这是在其他条件都符合下
非常重要的原则
选择相对市场表现强势的股票
比如说领涨板块的龙头股
但是卖出亏损的弱势股
2024年科技股强势
交易者选择买进NVIDIA
表现强于大盘
而不是某些的零售股
零售股
比如说没西百货表现不佳
在科技股普遍上涨的时候
选择涨幅领先的科技股来进行交易
注意领涨的板块
比如说科技股 AI股领涨
或者是强势的产业类股走势
通常都更值得关注
某些板块
比如说AI科技股代表经济活动
领涨时反映市场的强势值得关注
譬如说2025年运输板块
航运三雄关税的议题临场
交易者优先买入这个板块的股票
而不是落后的类股
好,那研究股票的特征
那研究股价走势
成交量活跃的程度和产业特征
譬如说产业板块轮动的分析
还有营收盈余报告同等的重要
因为除了技术性分析以外
研究公司基本面
资本结构营收盈余
还有市场的特性
成交量波动
选择适合交易的股票
那比如说交易者比较两只股票
走势温吞的电信类股呢
跟高波动的特斯拉
选择风险编号
可以高的呢
可以选择特斯拉进行短线的交易
好,那以上分析,还有呢,分析某公司财务报表了解他的资本结构和盈利的能力作为投资的参考
好,以上就是今天的内容
如果你喜欢我的影片,请记得按赞订阅,开启小铃铛
并请将影片分享给你所有想学习投资的朋友
我是朱立安,祝您顺利平安,谢谢
我们下次见